yeah hello welcome to a new video let's
kick off here and play if offer a change
it's against guy called water from
Argentina can't go to Petrov okay I'm
not a regular you for player so I go for
this line what usually tries to develop
quickly here and tries to walk Castle
long I Castle owner Kenny can you take
on a to think it so it's sometimes
possible maybe I should play play this
first to grab the bishop pair yeah I
smallest forced to take all right so is
there some alternative here Queenie
three or something or you can play
Queenie seven this is so useless so okay
let's just drop back here this method
meet the bishop pal but black of course
is very solid question is some does he
casts a long or does he Castle short
usually black black goes long here from
what I know in of games that are that
I've seen yeah so move like windy 79
yeah 27 look like very normal move maybe
Bishop to b5 trying to provoke a six
maybe it's a bit annoying the spin so
now I drop back so that maybe I have
some ideas like before be five if you
really wants to guess along
I but black and I think without any
problems just Castle short yeah of
course this was also possibility idea is
maybe night see form trying to reduce a
bishop air21 bishop so maybe I go b3
controlling the Seaforth grand
preventing this if he goes Knight g4 I
can preserve my III Bishop with Bishop
f4 hmm not sure if it's really uh huh
interesting
well okay I think I intended to cathur
short anyway right now I'm not quite
sure what what this move is doing yeah
but I was thinking huh I can just play a
three and then c4 kick it kick him back
so to say and then f4 in Bishop f3 and I
gained lots of moves with I mean lots of
tempe with moves that I really want to
play so I don't really understand this
point here so see form which is good
anyway now f4 f4 Bishop f3 there's
actually threatened speed to win be
seven so he needs to react in some way
so what now it's a very very nice
looking position still Bishop f3r do I
have something better this wouldn't be a
bad move
that don't see anything clearly better
now Bishop a7s maybe an idea yeah and
now going back here which still still
leaves b7 hanging but also rookie won
his on the cards to get in a nasty check
on the farm so he would need to play in
97 and then Wow 97 and now I have the
idea maybe queen to you to putting up
some pin here on the night so it cannot
castle and I've got the idea of Bishop
g4 which would be very annoying Bishop
g4 anyway yeah not bad yeah it's a good
move I think he either needs to he needs
a self-penned our play something he
really doesn't want to play yeah like
this here so um just back now yeah just
back and now I can can go Bishop d4 to
see three we should be four also
threatening Bishop g7 winning upon and
keeping a great position Bishop g7 kingi
727 okay so what now Queen to d2 yeah
the idea being Bishop b2 Quincy 3 and
also trying to double on the farm it
still needs to to play some moves to to
even um get your edge aight into play
okay maybe King King GA to h 7 ER okay
but I think doubling on default is good
anyway
hmm maybe I should have considered this
more let's say you spend some some more
time on this but okay it's still good
it's so good so what now Bishop b2
Quincy 3m looks very logical
yeah it's difficult for black I mean
King g8 John Quincy three not sure that
this is even now even the best move I
mean Claire quite some some attractive
possibilities okay once it wants to get
the night to you sexy em
ok let's go go here anyway 96 supply
Bishop g5 threatening only six and he
needs to play some ugly move to to even
cover all this rook g8 or something
okay I have no direct win here at least
like ones that don't see one so maybe
play the strengthening move okay this is
interesting it plans to take and play
night to your form I don't want to allow
that really ok let's drop back you might
play 94 anywhere but down it's still
quite some pressure
I don't quite see how to how to improve
him it looks very nice but still on
rather solid
yeah no I don't I don't have an idea
here Chuck this was was an idea not sure
what it's doing I know I'm on oh man I
just blended him up good all right yeah
man oops white I actually wanted to
offer draw but I didn't it I didn't
manage to hit the button yeah I could
have one on time also but this was a
wouldn't wouldn't be deserved really
yeah it was a very nice position but
somehow it was very very solid still in
a way yeah computer gives Bishop f3s
winning f3 to h5 yeah well I didn't have
the time this was yeah this was just a
hallucination of course he can he can
just take him this is so stupid and okay
this was just mature time scram okay
good could have won our time by just
playing some stupid move but now what
can you do it was a pretty good game i
think up to up to a certain point but he
he really found a pretty solid defensive
position maybe i could have could have
done something more here here and here
this looks really really good for white
difficult looks very good but it's not
so obvious how I should should improve
the position all right yeah I think it
was pretty answering anyway so let's um
start a new one